Transcriber: Ruqayah Al Qaba
المدقّق: Tarek Mamdouh
هاي
Thank You
هتكلم النهارده عن حاجه جميلة جدًا
إسمها Traditions التقاليد
أنا عارفة أنه الكلمة دي كبيرة جدًا
على أن نحن نقولها في سن صغير كده
بس حقيقي أنه لا مكنتش حبقى موجوده بينكم
هنا النهارده
أنا رحاب مظهر، ٢٤ سنة، من أسوان
الناس الي تعرف أسوان،
أول حاجه تجي في دماغكم صورة معينة لشخصين
ست لابسه عباية غامقة، مغطية وجهها،
وطبعًا مش بتتكلم
ورجل لابس جلابية لونها غامق، عمَّة،
وماسك عصاية
التقاليد هي مجموعة من الافعال الي قلدناها
نتيجة من أجدادنا، أهلنا زمان
وللأسف متقبلش التغيير،
ولا انه احنا نشكك فيها.
زي ممارسات، معتقدات، سلوك معين
من أكثر الجمل الي سمعتها زمان وأنا صغيرة
إنتِ بنت، مينفعش تكملي تعليم،
مينفعش تركبي عجل، مينفعش تسافري لوحدك
جمل كثير اوي سمعتها
سألتهم سؤال مهم ساعتها،
طب ايه الي ممكن ينفع؟
فجاوبو عليه، إنك تتجوز وتقعدي في البيت
كان عندي نقطة محتاجه أفهمها اول
قبل ما أعمل أي حاجه
هو أنا طلبت حاجه أكثر من حقوقي؟
هو أنتو ليه بتقولو كده؟
الفكرة عندنا في الصعيد، في أسوان بالأخص
هي أنه التقاليد مقدسة أكثر من الدين
بس نسبة التقييد تختلف من أُسرة لثانية
ولكن، كلو بالآخر بيأخذ على ثقافة واحدة
هي تمييز الرجل عن الست
وطبعًا أي تفاعل من الست،
بالنسبة لهم يبقى شيء مستنكر
قعدت كده لحد سادس ابتدائي
بعمل أبحاثي بيني وبين نفسي
هو ليه؟ ليه كل حاجة لا؟
سمعت جملة واحدة بس طول الوقت
قالو دي عادات وتقاليد يا حاجه
ولازم وحتمًا تنفذيها
قلتلهم طب ولو محصلش؟
قالولي يبقى أنه أنتِ مش كويسه
قعدت لحد فترة الإعدادي،
حسيت إني كبرت ولازم أعمل حاجه
أول حاجه عملتها أشتريت عجلة
وعشان أقدر أقنع أهلي بحاجة زي كدا
قلت لهم أصل أحنا معندناش أخوة أولاد
وبابا أغلب الوقت في الشغل
مين يجيب طلبات البيت؟
ثاني حاجة، اشتركت بجميع الأنشطة المدرسية
وخارج المدرسة كمان
وحضرت معسكر من أكبر معسكرات الصعيد
في محافظات البحر الأحمر
ده كان برعاية ووجود وزير التربية والتعليم
السابق، أستاذ محمود أبو النصر
أسست مناهضة للتدخين وحصلت على المركز الأول
في مستوى المحافظة رغم إني بنت
حصلت على الطالبة المثالية على مستوى
المحافظة سنتين عالتوالي ٢٠١٦ و ٢٠١٧
(تصفيق)
Thank You
جت فترة الثانوية العامة وكانت بالنسبة لي
Turning point
أول حاجه قابلتها هي فكرة علمي / أدبي
و “لا أدبي بلاش، علمي أكيد”
قلت لهم طب لو مش علمي؟
قالولي يبقى تتجوزي وتقعدي في البيت
أهلي طبعًا ما أخذوش رأيي معملوش أي حاجة
غير أنه هم راحو واختارو علمي
وأنا ساعتها مكنتش عارفة أعمل ايه
بس أنا مقدرتش أقبل بالتغيير ده
وجاء في يوم من الأيام
سمعت عندنا في الإذاعة المدرسية
أنه اليوم هو آخر يوم
لتحديد أو تغيير الشعبة
فإلى من يرغب التوجه لمكتب “فلان الفلاني”
حتى نهاية اليوم
ساعتها قلت لازم أعمل حاجه
وتحركت فورًا، وحولت للأدبي
وبما أنه البلد عندنا صغيرة جدًا
وكل الناس عارفة بعض
اتصلوا بوالدي فجأة وعرفوه بحاجه زي كدا
بس هو قال لهم جملة
ممكن أغلبكم ميبقاش عارفها
قال لهم “الي يقدر يجل، يجل”
ودي بالصعيدي عندنا يعني
الي يتحمل، يشيل
في نفس المرحلة بتاعت الثانوية العامة دي
قابلت صديقة لي، من الصعيد،
وعندها نفس فكرة التغيير
عرفتني عن Concept جديد في حياتي
هو المِنَّح Scholarships
طبعًا فورًا توجهت ل Google
سألت وعرفت يعني ايه مِنَّح
وايه الفرق بين المِنحَّة والبعثة (البعثات)
وفورًا، كنت بثانوية عامة آخر سنة،
وقبل امتحاناتي،
قدمت بستة مِنَّح لسفارات مختلفة
انقبلت رسمي بأربعة
بس حبيت إني أكمل بواحدة معينة لأسبابٍ ما
كانت تابعة للسفارة الأمريكية
ومؤسسة AMIDEAST لو تعرفوها
كنت ساعتها مش عارفة أقنع أهلي إزاي
ببعدي أربع سنين عنهم على الأقل
وسفري للقاهرة
الحل الوحيد كان ساعتها
أنه أنا أخذهم من أيديهم
كنت بتعمد أحيانًا أنه أنا آخذ والدي
في بعض الأنشطة والمعسكرات وغيرها
عشان يشوف الحاجات الي احنا مش عايشينها
أو الي احنا مش شايفنها
أخيرًا أقنعت أسرتي بالسفر
وأنه أنا أكمل في المنحة
بس رغم رفض جميع درجات القرابة الأولى
وسمعت طبعًا كلام كثير ما كان يعجبني
ويخليني حاجة من الاثنين: يا يخليني تعيسة
يا يخليني مثمرة
جاءت فترة الجامعة ووصلت القاهرة
في اغسطس ٢٠١٨
كانت برفقة والدي طبعًا
استلمت سكني
وقبولي في إحدى أكبر برامج الشراكة في مصر
من ثلاث جامعات: ,Kean University
Ocean County College, Ain Shams University
(تصفيق)
بس برضو ما استسلمت، حصل حاجات كثير بعدها
درست طبعًا في الثلاث جامعات
حصلت على كورسات كثير في
English, Soft Skills, Computer Skills
رحت معسكرات أكثر
لدرجة أنه أنا اشتغلت Freelance لحد الآن
في شركة اسمها WellSpring
بتغير أفكار ناس كثير في المجتمع
والصعيد بالأخص
بس على هيئة معسكرات
فبالتالي سافرت اكثر من ٨٥٪ من محافظات مصر
إتطوعت كثير جدًا، أكثر من ٤٠٠٠ ساعة
في ٤ سنين
في مؤسسات ومراكز ومستشفيات كثير جدًا
كان أهمهم والي فرق معايا جدًا
هي مستشفى بهية ودوري في الدعم النفسي عندهم
أسست مبادرة إسمها بتساعد
الأطفال اللاجئين أنهم يتعلموا حاجات جديدة
قراية، كتابة، برمجة، رسم،
كل الي كانوا يحبوه
بس ساعتها حصلت حاجة جميلة جدًا
كنت عمري ما أتخيلها
المبادرة دي حصلت على المركز ١٧
على مستوى الوطن العربي
وسافرت الكويت في إحدى المؤتمرات
برعاية وزير الشباب الكويتي
وكانت أول مرة أسافر برا مصر لوحدي
طبعًا اتخرجت من الجامعة بتقدير عام امتياز
وحاليًا بشتغل Quality Assurance Specialist
في شركة من أكبر شركات المعاملات المالية
والبنوك هي Money Fellows
(تصفيق)
طبعًا مقدرش أنسى أهم حاجة
كانت بتتكرر طول الوقت
وهي أني “أتجوز وأقعد في البيت”
حقيقي عملتها
بالنهاية إلي عاوزة اقولو هو
Title of the talk من وجهة نظري
?Do Traditions Hold Us Back
لا مش دائمًا
في تقاليد ومعتقدات لولاها
ما كنت رح أعمل حاجات كثير آوي في دماغي
من أهمها: التفاؤل وأنه يبقى دماغي ناشفة
ما لم أضر أحد يعني
التمسك بالأصالة والحدود المتفق عليها
من ناحية الدين والمجتمع بأشمله
مش مجموعة معينة منه
بس عالوجه الآخر
كان في بعض التقاليد والمعتقدات
الي كان لازم أتخلص منها
عشان ما أكون إنسان عادي وأكون إنسان مميز
وأعمل حاجات مميزة كثير
تفيدني أنا ومجتمعي والأسرة بتاعتي بعدين
بس في الآخر، الشاطر هو إلي يعملMixing
من Traditions عمومًا
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
(تصفيق)